what's up sweet tits uh you gotta check
out my fall dates all on sale now at
salvolcanocomedy.com
we got uh toronto we have hamilton
canada ontario there richmond virginia
hershey pennsylvania second show added
knoxville uh atlanta second show added
birmingham louisville evansville
jacksonville tampa orlando sacramento
san jose santa rosa all on sale right
now savilecanoecomedy.com merch is up
there too uh yeah that's my next dates
and that's going to be it for a little
while so make sure you get out there
thanks guys
all right and then this head hey folks
joe derosa here from the taste buds
podcast i got dates i got dates i got
dates go to joederosainfo.com
to check them out you can also buy your
tickets there get all the show info you
need
first up atlantic city new jersey then i
will be heading off to san diego
california i am also hitting somerville
in massachusetts after that north
carolina
and some other stuff
joederosainfo.com new dates are being
added all the time and if you're in new
york city come to joey roses if you're
not in new york city and you want to
make a trip come to joey rose's joey
roses nyc joeyrosesnyc.com for all the
info on the spot that serves both
alcohol and sandwiches at amazing prices
opening tuesday through sunday at 12 p.m
every day
taste joeyrosesnyc.com they coming to
the mic talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like two
fools gonna fight but only one food can
be right
hey
welcome to
t-a-s-t-e
buds
this is a sort of part two
don't write letters yes okay this is
just they will remain unopened this is a
spiritual sequel as they call it yeah
we're here to battle mcdonald's versus
wendy's
uh i mean i'm sorry mcdonald's versus
pizza hut but before i already be here
with wendy's uh
let's see how pizza does today
and i love pizza if pizza beats
mcdonald's and your mcdonald's goes if
mcdonald's goes oh for two in two
battles
oh
i would check their stock prices fair
enough because we we do move the needle
here
so
you wanted a cliffhanger in the last
episode
we ended with that i made a phone call
to our friend steve burke called willie
nelson
why do you know
willie nelson's granddaughter which by
the way i have a sticker of willie
nelson
on my weed box and i told you i started
collecting stickers again as an adult i
did her podcast called music is funny
it's a great podcast
uh what's her name her and her band me
raelynn and she and her bandmate jb do
the podcast together they're both great
people
they're great people
anyway when i was doing the podcast they
brought up that i played drums and i
said yeah
and they go
um do you want to play drums on our next
single
wow
and i was like yeah would they ask you
that prior to knowing your skill set
surprise me too
yeah like what if you got it was like
surprised me too
like
so yeah so i don't know
so they said if you can get to nashville
we'll do it and i said okay
so here i am suddenly driving to
nashville not because of that but
because i thought well steve lives there
i'll go to nashville wait they asked you
to play drums after you saw them that
time
not so you didn't haven't played the
drums yet
no no i'm on this road trip
and i'm like should i go to nashville it
seems like more fun
al jackson says go to asheville all
right but you went there
and then they asked you to play the
drums no no it was before they asked me
on the podcast they said if you ever
find back when
got it some weeks ago so now is the time
when you'd be playing the drums yeah
holy smokes so i literally text them and
i just go hey turns out i'm actually
coming to nashville tomorrow
are you around and they were like yeah
we're around
so i start driving to nashville
uh
i drove through kansas kansas was
astounding
because it was the opposite of utah
there was nothing
obstructing the land in any way it's
just flat land everywhere you can see
and that's where i saw the sunset
truly and
here's what's so interesting relevant to
what that guy said to me
about always look behind you it was
setting behind me as i was driving
and the sky was bright red it literally
looked like the cover of like of a dc
comics
like graphic novel like where superman
is going to clash in the air
you know what i mean with like black
atom or something like it was it looked
insane
and then everything in front of me i
could see the dark starting to have it
was wild
it was wild open road yeah
lightning
however far in the distance just it was
crazy
that was amazing and also terrifying
because when it got dark as i said
yes
and that's the night i slept
i tried to sleep
in a uh hotel again that was oh this
time
until holiday inn i got a 15
what was that one like did you sleep on
the towels again i couldn't i laid there
for an hour and i go i can't sleep and i
just left i remember i remember getting
like that i went and slept in my car
that night yeah that's why you slept in
your car you know i went i slept in a
motel room once after like the prom
and uh we all did like at the jersey
shore and it was so disgusting that i
went to the cvs and i bought a poncho
yeah and then i cut the poncho open and
i basically laid on
like an open garbage bag yeah to sleep
through the night
yeah
yeah so i i it's it's it's crazy yeah so
i got to i mean
sleeping in your car would you put it in
park and then just put the you stayed in
the front seat and put it backwards yeah
i just tilted the seat back i had a pit
my friend amy gave me a pillow and
blanket which came in super handy
and uh because she thought you would
sleep in the car she's like you never
know you might want to pull over and
take a nap you might not be able to
drive anymore very nice amy
and it came in handy and i just and i
slept like a baby talk to me about
nashville
i got to nashville i spent the night
with steve byrne
let's spend the night together
you got a song for everything
it's a song for you thank you
is it for me or is it for you it's the
name of your name or song oh oh oh
yeah i spent the night with steve byrne
we had a blast we went to this amazing
old school like frank sinatra style
steakhouse we ate this huge meal
we laughed a ton
uh we hung out with his wife and her
sister and some other comics that were
in town we went to this place i forget
the name of it it has the best
enchiladas i've ever had in my life
i or empanadas excuse me that i've ever
had in my life
uh it was amazing it was just a it was a
blast of a night next day i got up
went to this met the studio uh wake up
met raylan jb at the studio played drums
on the song
uh
wait so they just taught you the song
right then and there i knew they were
they said they sent it to me they sent
me a copy when was the last time you
played drums here's how much i didn't i
didn't know you play drums
so how how how
rusty were you on these drums i knew the
song already because they had sent it to
me and i was listening to it it wasn't
but did you practice it on drums
practice it in my car driving to
nashville
that's insane i mean it's like running
into my brain i'm not saying like i
could have sat there and played rush
but i mean you know i was able to handle
this song hope i mean rush unless they
send it to rush hurry hurry
paul abdul that's enough okay
enough is enough is enough
i know it's a fun game for me
it sucks for me
[Laughter]
anyway record the song
then
realized
holy [ __ ]
i'm like four hours from atlanta
my best friend from high school
james pink stone lives in atlanta
his birthday was a few weeks ago my
birthday is in a week
i'm gonna drive to atlanta and celebrate
my birthday with one of my best friends
in the entire world this is unbelievable
why was your schedule so open
i just moved a couple things i had spots
it was like [ __ ] that i was just like
okay i'm not coming back like it wasn't
anything like crazy right the one thing
maybe i'm crazy the one major thing i
had to do and they indulged me i had a
meeting with q and the crew at the
production company okay and i was like
guys i know i'm supposed to be there can
i please just do do this over zoom and
they're like yeah dude all i want to do
is
zoom zoom please stop
please
i hate it
stop
in the name of love
anyway
i go down to atlanta we
my friend jim and i have
the biggest day ever we just party our
asses off
we're catching up we haven't been able
to hang properly in a long time because
of cove and all that [ __ ]
this is in atlanta now yeah this is on a
saturday
are you staying with him or you got
another hotel room no i stayed with him
he's a spare room he's paying his wife
for the spirit
we had the best time ever man it was so
awesome um and then on sunday that was a
saturday and then on sunday around 10
p.m now i'm easy
i just was like no sunday night not
morning i'm easy like sunday
around 10 p.m i was just like you know
what
i think i'm ready to like head back
and i
jumped in my car
drove through the night pulled over
again at a rest stop or a truck stop
slept for a few hours
kept driving got to my parents house
that morning
got to see my folks
parents just don't understand you know
they do though they they did
got to see my folks
now here's the other part
in pennsylvania jersey jerry here's the
other part of the trip that was
happening to me maybe it was the
transition off the meds maybe it was
just life i don't know i've been very
depressed about approaching my 45th
birthday i'm not happy about it okay but
so then what i do is i try to drink
i try to drink it away
which is bad
the exact opposite of what i should be
doing
uh but this is what i mean with like i
gotta face some emotions i've been
crying a lot lately
women what when did you cry less it's
just emotions
it's
it will be little things that
it will be like movie things
like and i do cry movies but like i'm
talking like i mean i watched big the
other night i was like
let him cry
all right all right if the tears fall
down
right now okay
i know you're doing it because you know
what upsets me doing it and doing it and
doing it right i represent queen she was
raised out in brooklyn and it is
impressive
it is impressive i do you know
no dude i've been crying a lot lately
and you're missing crying from aerosmith
which is what you should have sang there
but i've been crying a lot lately so i
took my parents
this is really the end of the story
i took my parents to see elvis because
steve byrne told me it was so good
mm-hmm i heard that from him told me
he'd saw it three times he said he
didn't see the actor he saw elvis is
what he said
yes he only saw it three times and he
told me the ending
like almost haunted him for days
so i was like all right i got to see
this because i didn't had to have any
interest in it
so i'm like that'll be perfect to do
with my folks i'll take my parents to
see all this
we go to say it
uh thank god
we we went so late that we couldn't get
three seats together we had to sit three
separate seats
all three of you no one sat next to each
other
no how late did you go
they all the only seats left together
were in the front row but their back row
had three separate okay so we got those
thank god because
they would have seen it thank god i'm a
country boy they would have seen me
weeping
multiple times throughout the movie
throughout the elvis movie throughout
the elvis movie when the end of this
thing hit
i was crying so much that when the
lights came on for the credits i ran
like i had to go to the bathroom it was
[ __ ] i had to go into the bathroom
and finish crying because i didn't want
my parents to see me crying because i
was so embarrassed
i came out of the bathroom
i'm trying to like make my eyes not look
red my mom was like oh my god i loved it
so much the ending i almost started
crying again i walk away
for two days after i got back so it was
so emotional i'm gonna ruin the ending
for you gotta see it okay well i know he
does
you foolish child
you foolish cheap joke child foolish
hearts you just hear me you don't
deserve to hear the ending of this movie
for two days i'm back in new york i get
back to new york
which by the way was met immediately
with my parking garage telling me
they're gonna charge me 200 more a month
because the car is too big
i mean as soon as i got back to new york
everything that man said to me on the
mountain that resonated i was like
you [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] you
[ __ ] like i see you johnny
listen to me
you have to stop doing that
it's making me mad
stop doing it
mad world i'm really sure okay
let's get serious
let's get serious and fall in love
anyway
for two days after elvis for two days
after elvis
seeing my folks when i would talk about
somebody i would start crying
whoa
yeah what is in the film that touched
something in you do you want me to give
you full ending spoiler yeah i don't
know because that's also i mean all
right you got to work at your sk let's
just spoil this
yeah yeah you're not going to do elvis i
i was intending to but i got to be
honest i i did look at the like the uh
trailer and it felt a little bit like
champion i thought yeah it's like if
it's like if oliver stone jfk style
directed a movie about elvis no it's so
insane like the way it's done creatively
i mean
it's so fascinating to look at
keep healing fascination
stop stop
it has all the emotion in it that you
want
i just want to stop
and tell you how i feel about you babe
please continue
but you're having fun with it
it's it's a good bit for the audience if
i was listening to this right now i
would have turned the episode off really
yes turn the episode off
with that sweet sound
every fourth time it's funny it's the
three getting to the fourth that i hate
uh but what is it that made you cry
oh you wanna the ending yeah several
parts of the movie may make you cry what
is the idea that made you cry
like getting older what is the
well there's a thing i'll tell you what
there's a there's a part where he sings
on the 68 comeback special
he's getting pushed to do a christmas
song at the end of the special and then
bobby kennedy gets killed
and he's also still reeling from martin
luther king getting killed and he ends
the special by writing a new song that's
a protest song and then the song just it
kills you dude it's a real song though
it's a real song yeah it's like you
actually ended the special with it if
you watch the real song in the ghetto
no it's like i don't even know what it's
called i've never heard it but he's like
it you know it's like in the ghetto you
used to make me cry yeah it's well
that's a great song
but no he's like if i can walk then i
can try you know like it's what he's
like right we've got to be better you
know songs but the end
the end
it's it's you know you know where it's
headed and he's in a car at the airport
with
like their private plane with him and
priscilla like dropping his daughter
he's like giving
the daughter back to priscilla to take
and she's like
please
uh i might start crying
no do it no way
she's like there's a facility please go
to it because he's so [ __ ] up
and he's like and he's literally sitting
there and he's going
i'm done baby he's like i never did
anything that was last and i'm a joke
like it's horrible dude
and then they get out of the plane it's
the last time they see each other and he
goes like this he goes last time because
he yeah and like the their song came in
priscilla
in the movie i don't know if that in
real life
but uh
but you know uh that song i will always
love you i can't help myself falling oh
sure of course yeah i think that might
be wise
no no it's i can't help yeah
but anyway
[Music]
yeah like to make it emotional yeah no
no no yeah no no don't no no no the
filmmaker knew what he was doing this
wasn't it i thought i would i thought
i'd make it a thing right now for us the
uh
[Music]
no he goes like this he goes he
they're on the runway he goes i will
always love you like that and it's
[ __ ]
i know what you're kidding me right now
and he gets on the plane he waves to her
it's
brutal then he flies off
he's crying
holy [ __ ] dude he flies off
and then
uh i i just wanted to fly tom hanks who
plays colonel parker
uh he's he's doing he's like narrates it
how are those jowls in that
tom axe is incredible okay the kid is
incred they're both they're [ __ ]
everybody's phenomenal anyway
teak says i six weeks later i saw elvis
sing for the last time and he goes he
couldn't even stand and it shows
it's a real video stand in the place
where you live god dude please
uh he's he it's a real video you can see
oh jesus it's a real video you can see
it online on youtube but he's playing
he's playing um unchained melody on a on
piano
and he's singing it he's forgetting the
lyrics right
oh he nails it and that's like what's so
miraculous okay because he was at a
state physically where he could barely
stand up he was so [ __ ] up and he
nails it and it's beautiful
but he looks
terrible
and they start for the first time in the
movie intercutting the actor with the
real thing oh yeah
and dude you just it it's oh my god it's
that good
i wasn't gonna see it i wasn't gonna see
it wow it's brutal dude and then and
then it starts playing like the elvis
died
first and then of course the last line
is elvis has left the building uh
dude
i so this the map that i'm crying right
now is nothing compared to what happened
to me in the theater i am telling you
dude i had to run to the bathroom
because i was like i'm gonna run to you
i'm a blubbering mess i saw nope last
night by the way oh you did how was it i
thought it was good
it was fine okay it was fine as a horror
like that's some scary part it's like
it's like signs but not as good as
science
signs everywhere a science [ __ ]
understands that breaking my mind do
this
one of his best friends literally crying
instead of saying like why do you think
you're crying a lot lately
let me think of the next song i can sing
this is the friendship
this is the friendship you get
this is the friendship i deserve that i
don't know what's your favorite friends
for good
times way you cried at two tom hanks
movies huh you're just crying no then i
watched big the other night and i was a
[ __ ] mess yeah big
biggest is one of my favorites of all
time but i was a mess at
here's the thing though i'm a mess of
things like it's not just like the elvis
thing was sad right heartbreaking it's
not just that heartbreak
it's like it's like things that anything
that's like sentimental people making up
on camera
like big it was the it was it was like
when the two oh my god i'm gonna cry
again when the two kids are walking down
the street again when they're together
again yeah
together again
i know i can't take turning 45.
yeah
no dude i know
i know dude i can't i've been hearing
this i've been having we were going
through the crisis
is this what it is it is it's the
midlife it's the midlife
i can't believe i'm even saying that
but it is we're having the midlife i
mean we're halfway to 90.
now when's the last time you cried so
i've talked yesterday today something
like that
maybe this today tom hanks movie he
didn't no no just the thought of tom
hanks so happy with him
i cry often
oh my god i'm an emotional fellow
especially lately
coming off a weird couple of years and
going into some stuff and
i i don't know i i i you know i i try to
keep in touch with my
i try to keep mental inventory and a lot
there's a lot of stuff that scares the
[ __ ] out of me remembering big when he
throws the ball when he goes home
yeah right before he goes back to his
girlfriend and he goes i want to go home
yes and she doesn't know what he's
talking about yeah
but she doesn't believe him yeah because
it's so crazy
zolt zoltai right
zoltar yeah forget-me-nots is playing
when they're on the trampoline right yes
when he walks in his house
opening the door triggers the big
apartment is the inspiration i have for
my own apartment
yeah i know that's i always wanted that
too
i had a loft in l.a that wasn't flat it
was it was like yours here
i had a loft in la and i made it kind of
like as much like like i had multiple
arcade games in it and like like why do
people get so adult with their
furnishings
the house should still be a fun house to
my opinion i agree but sometimes
somebody like the other day we had we
had a can i kick it meeting and i was on
zoom
and they trashed me for the way my
apartment was well you have a lot of
memorabilia
and things that we collect which is it's
if you had a bigger house you'd probably
have that in your den or your basement
you know but it's it's it's it's but
it's what you like and what you use al
jackson said maya
this is so funny you said my apartment
looked like i had a 15 year old son that
died
and we
and we didn't change anything
it hurt it really hurt me it hurt me
like in my heart because i was like he's
right it doesn't look like that
i got to get an office oh [ __ ]
i gotta get an office to put myself i'm
trying to get a fire pole in in there
now dude not in your office you know
fire pole in the you know in the other
thing oh
did i tell you that no i didn't tell you
that you you're gonna be a pole guy to
get from the first floor to the second
floor no i'm in one area of the house
have you been known to go down a pole
no
okay not really it's a brash it's not
it's not like a stripper pole it's a
fireball well
oh if you want to strip on
i'm not going to stop anybody what
inspired that
uh
big
like being fun
i don't know it's just a fun idea we
should have a big viewing party with
youtube we're cool that'd be fun a
viewing party of what just record it and
put it out you guys reacting to big in
real time oh i would love that i oh i
haven't seen it in so long i used to
watch it endlessly my apartment now you
guys know i have a a basketball hoop in
it yeah uh i have a swing
some arcade games i have some bubble gum
machines i got like i don't know i just
try to have fun you're like pee-wee
herman yeah there's a scene there's a
scene in big that is so insane
i can't believe it works
i can't believe it works it's hilarious
where he calls his mom
to be because he's she thinks the kid
has been kidnapped
and she he calls his mom and pretends
like he's the kidnapper just so he can
let her know he the kids okay yes and
he's at work
and he's like i just want you to know
he's okay
and then she's like he's like you can i
can't let you talk to him but you can
ask me a question only he could answer
yeah and then he goes
he goes she goes what did i sing to him
as a baby and then the joke it's
supposed to be funny because tom hanks
was like don't you want to ask him
something else because he doesn't want
to sing it yeah and then he starts
singing it and it's hilarious and john
lovitz plays his like cubicle neighbor
yeah and john levitz is looking at him
like what the [ __ ] is wrong with this
guy
and that is cross cut with the mother
devastated crying that her son is
missing yeah
and
but the takeaway is is that it's funny
like right it's such a crazy scene i was
like holy [ __ ] man
what was that song that he sings with
the kid
um to that like oh i'm walking around
coco
yeah that's what he sings to convince
the kids
yeah shimmy shimmy rock i said it i said
it yeah so you're wearing credit cool
i'm hot stock me in the stomach two more
times they nail the beginning sequence
of of them together
the two kids who's elizabeth perkins yes
she follows me on twitter i've never met
her she does
yeah that happened i don't know she just
i followed her and she followed me wow
and then she's liked some of my tweets
but anyway really
um
they never where are we
we're about 30 minutes all right we got
to get to the battle jesus christ this
is crazy part three i mean you
wanna go part three joey's birthday
extravaganza part two and then we'll go
into the battle and park me i love
episode one is your road trip episode
two is you weeping
i'll do it i mean let's have fun with
having fun
i'll do it i know if you came for a
battle
it's just it was joe's birthday we
decorated
he's been gone for weeks he's having a
a crisis of conscience no you're having
a midlife cry with doing this he drove
across country there's stories of plenty
yeah and
you know i'm engaged
and i know that's i look i don't know if
i don't know what in in the pie chart of
what people tune in for
or the venn diagram i don't know how
much of it is just us people are also a
battle of foods
people also like to like they will the
fans will write and say
please do a second podcast where you
talk about music or please do a second
we talk because we like hearing you guys
talk about this stuff so i know there
are people that will appreciate this
conversation
i hope i hope people aren't like no
battle nah i
we do have the most fickle
but we do unfair fans of the world
the masses are not the squeaky people no
the master's
a nice time seeing you and i catch up
this is our first
real life so pimp let's bill it as
our first ever three-part episode
joe's birthday extravaganza part one
whatever we call part two and then the
third episode is the battle it looks
like he's double fisting oh yeah yeah
well i wasn't gonna say because you know
sometimes we have
people that watch that maybe i'm sorry
say that i know i met some of them did i
tell you when we had the kids at the i
did
the kids that came to julie rose's with
their parents to get lunch
well they were welcome well not kid not
kid they were like 12 and 14. they were
with their parents though you were a
child
that's great i love that it was so sweet
i was like this is amazing i never
thought of my life when i have a 12 year
old fan
you know enjoy yourself
take only what you need from it isn't
that kids
i am gmt
oh i love that song kids oh wait let's
get back to big yeah let's get back to
big speaking of kids
they nail
what it was like for us
no no nothing to do with it big no too
late
now it's too late baby can we have a
conversation can we have a conversation
will we can we have a conversation a
little coming out with a little bit of
conversation
they nail what it is like to be a kid
our our age bracket what was my favorite
movie
when we grew up that sequence
when it's like
they're playing stickball and they're
pretending they're doing the baseball
announcers
they're riding their bikes they see the
girl that he likes
the thing that
like blew me away
that i'm sure as a kid i took for
granted
and when i saw it now i was like holy
[ __ ] yes
when he's looking at the new baseball
cards
and he's going got it got it got it got
it got it got it and like the the fact
that there was a time where you could
have like where that would i would have
had it all memorized like i would have
remembered every
single baseball card i owned i i lived
that yes i knew what i'm saying i i knew
everyone i'm talking a thousands of them
yeah i knew what i had i was obsessive i
used to sit in my room and make lists
and make piles of duplicates and who i
needed and who i could trade them for
and what the value of them was remember
getting the baseball card price book
guides yeah i don't even know if they
that exists existed
yeah i heard i heard and maybe you could
look this up correct me if i'm wrong
better what's better than help better
help better help better help better help
folks you got to take care of your mind
all right especially in this
insane environment we are living in
things
the outside world seems to be getting
crazier by the day uh and a lot of us
feel that a lot of us are in this
existential
you know drift uh you know after covid
and and and and still during covet and
it's just a crazy world
uh and there's a lot for us to take in
and and you know what
the last thing you need to do is
pressure yourself
on why you don't quite understand it or
why you're not able to maybe work some
of the mental
stuff out on your own you shouldn't have
to
help is okay
and help from better help is pretty
pretty great all right this is
this is this is therapy geared to help
you in any way you need it
need to access it i've been in and out
of therapy my entire life and i and i'm
a fan of therapy
but
it's a very bureaucratic process it can
cost a lot of money it can take a lot of
time
uh i i'll be honest with you i had my
therapist tell me recently that there is
now a waiting list
uh at the clinic she works at
and that if i were to halt
treatment for a certain period of time
meaning a few weeks
i would lose my spot in line and it
would go to somebody else and i would
probably not have a chance of getting
back in for
who knows six months a year this is come
on this is not the way we should all be
living we deserve the help we want and
that's it it's that simple better help
is here to give it to you all right it's
online therapy offered through video or
phone or live chat okay you don't have
to be on camera if you don't want to
it's more affordable than most in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist another 48 hours this is all
catered to you to get you what you need
now not later now
our listeners
are going to get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com tastebuds that's
b e
tt
dot com slash taste buds again ten
percent off go now betterhelp.com
tastebuds
folks let's talk about one of our
sponsors bespoke post
take your summer adventures to the next
level with the bespoke post and their
new seasonal lineup of must-have box of
awesome collections bespoke posts
partners with small businesses and
emerging brands to bring you the most
unique goods every month that's what i
love most about these guys
they're not only sending you a box of
cool stuff which a lot there are
services out there that do that
uh you know and it's a great cool new
industry that's out there but bespoke
post is making it their goal
to to partner with small businesses
i love mom and pop stuff i love small
businesses i love the unique products
and services you can get out of those
small businesses things that you never
would find in a big box store and i love
that bespoke is really focused on that
it's so cool because a lot of these
small businesses exist in places where
you might not access them or come across
them who knows you know the internet is
great and convenient it can't bring you
everything bespoke post is trying to
help
make that a little easier for you which
i think is so cool like there's a knife
in the terror box that's made by a
company called bare bones based in salt
lake city
there's another knife called the
damascus it's made by but buck and bear
knives located in pennsylvania where i'm
from
uh i'm laughing because i just love
these these unique little places these
these companies little i don't mean that
you know they're they're mighty they're
small but mighty hot sauces from small
brands all over the country including
places from texas nevada california this
is just so cool this is the kind of
stuff you'd find like when you're
you know window shopping on a road trip
or something and they're putting it into
a box and sending it right to you
box of awesome has everything in it that
you need
for the summer it's got tons of cool
stuff to get started take the quiz at
box of awesome.com you're going to
answer some questions and then they're
going that's going to help them pick the
right box of awesome for you they
release new boxes every month across a
ton of different categories each box is
valued at around 70
but you only pay a fraction of that
price
plus with each box of austin awesome
you're supporting again small businesses
ninety percent of everything that comes
in your box of austin awesome is from a
small up-and-coming brand that's so cool
so get 20 off your first monthly box
when you sign up at box of awesome dot
com and enter the code taste buds at
checkout that's box of awesome.com using
promo code tastebuds for 20 off your
first box box of awesome dot com
code taste buds
i heard that baseball card the industry
as a whole
something went south it took a full
nosedive and they found out that a lot
of things that they were saying were
rare which would bring the price up
indeed was not true and the whole thing
had a reset and and most baseball cards
lost all of their value and the market
came crashing down that is what i heard
the cards are worthless now because
nobody's buying um but
did you know there are still baseball
card shops
no they're still collecting the baseball
card
dude are you kidding like
that was my life so i just did i just
did i just did a uh audio book with a
special thing records
um i don't know when it'll be out but we
just recorded it but it was all the
op-ed pieces i wrote for penthouse over
like a year and a half about like
societal stuff
[Laughter]
when did you write op-eds of penthouse
in the middle of drum solos
when i lived in l.a
did you live there are worlds to me babe
they're world's top ed pieces for
penthouse yeah
for two years i did he's a pant house
you're just finishing my song you're
getting into it i wrote i wrote short
harf i wrote short horror fiction for
them too or for a couple couple
different places for fangoria and for
other yeah
but
fangoria oh my gosh so i
but i so we did a recording we recorded
all me reading all of them
like for a record like for like an audio
book record right unbelievable but the
intro to the record i wrote a special
intro for it that set up why these
writing for penthouse meant something to
me and it was about this is circling
back now to whatever
it was about
um when i
was a kid
the collegeville that was the town i
grew up in the collegeville newsstand
and the collegeville newsstand was just
that it was a newsstand it was when you
had to buy your newspaper
or magazine
as a thing it was there was no such
thing as digital tangible right tangible
and they had comic books
that's a word i'm looking for physical
copy yeah yeah the uh hard copy yeah
not tangible uh
not palpable uh
god anyway i know what you mean yeah
it's a tactic not texting that what
you're waiting for i don't know okay but
they had
uh they had
comic books
in every magazine you could ever think
of yeah they'd come books and then they
had nudie mags which when you're like 11
you're like
that's like valhalla to try to get to
the nudi mag section
but
you know what i mean but like we had in
the one shopping center there was the
collegeville newsstand then there was a
there was like the collectible shop
where the guy had baseball cards
so you'd go to the newsstand you'd buy
the comic books and the baseball cards
and then you could go to the collectible
shop it was a whole thing
it was a lifestyle it was a lifestyle
yeah it was like you were on a circuit
as a kid you were in the circuit i was
talking about there was a 7-eleven right
there so you go your candy slurpee
you ran the whole thing i know nothing
was better and here's what i think i
think that we're just all nostalgic for
that time in our lives and so everyone's
that stuff means something to you and i
where it doesn't mean anything to anyone
today but we feel like
it's the reason that we at a certain
point you can unless you're really
really into it but you kind of stop
listening to music because you go a
little more out of or things like music
in this day and age
i have grown out of
i've grown further away from
the most like new music
because i don't listen as much and when
you know it's almost like when like
my heart's not in the music right now
right like you know don't get me wrong
i'll discover a new artist a new band
i'll flip out but it's not like when we
were younger where you knew everything
that was relevant everything that was
out everything on the radio everything
on you just knew everything to an extent
because
you were of that time like right now i
hear a song i don't like i turn it like
i just don't listen to it and then i you
know i'm always like well why don't i
just listen to the stuff that makes me
feel good that makes me feel nostalgic
to stuff that i know is what i love or
dig to find new music of that era so
then to listen to the [ __ ] that's on
today which is the age-old thing of like
the old people being like ah turn that
garbage off but it's true and it's no
one's fault but just psychology and life
that's interesting because what happens
to me what happens is you you can skip
past something so quickly because
there's so many options
right you're not forced to listen to
anything anymore there was a time where
you were forced in the sense of like all
you had in the car was a radio that's it
maybe a tape deck also music was so much
more communal i think sure sure
but like but my point is is when you're
driving and fm radio is the primary
option for entertainment you find your
and also switching stations is not just
it's like you had to turn the dial and
everything oh yeah when all of it
becomes that complicated suddenly you're
you're locked into something you don't
feel like changing it because it's a
process right it's a hassle and then you
suddenly are going you know what i like
that song i i
wouldn't have come around on yeah yeah
that happened to me for the first time
in a while in a record store because i
saw and of course i can't remember the
name of the band now but i bought the
record but i saw a record
in a record store
in don't you dare
in nashville
you could you remember you said you
couldn't
you don't remember the name of the band
right i had one for that but are you
going to do d12
my band
they don't even know the name of my band
yeah yeah that's really good i was going
to do band on the run mine was better it
was because you're getting you know what
i'm going to be honest
pick your spots
remember that do you ever see that clip
from home milton
richard pryor or milt baros says like
his sister died or something terrible
that richard breyer laughs because it's
awkward
and then milton berle goes
i told you once
i'll tell you again
pick your spots baby pick your spots and
richard goes okay sweetheart it's very
awkward okay
anyway
um
that wasn't a great story yeah you were
happy this was happening on the radio
here's the other no no no no no no i'm
in a record store
i see a record cover and i'm like man
that record cover is so cool
i was like i'm just going to listen to
the record while i'm here and because i
was listening to it on my headphones and
i was distracted
right
by digging through crates or whatever i
was doing
i wasn't
like eh you know what i mean judging it
and then all of a sudden i looked up and
i was four songs in and i was like
this is awesome i'm gonna buy this
record
and i was like if i if i had just done
what we all [ __ ] do which is i'm in
my apartment i'm going to put this on
you here 30 seconds you go no no no no
with that next next i'll [ __ ] it i'll go
back to the thing i already like you
know what i mean that's why actually the
last couple years
daily almost now i the way i consume
music in my home is records
i pick an album and i let it play
through i just got the it's in the mail
today i'm so excited to get it when i
get home i got the hook up so i can hook
my record player up to my sonos now
which is going to be awesome i love it
yeah remember when you were driving well
also there was like okay this is k rock
is alternative rock this is easy
listening this year is
hot 97 it's hip hop and then you got
like classic rock and it was like there
was like five stations
you know what i mean that was all you
had and i remember driving in the car
like you ever like you ever driving
somewhere and like other friends or in
other cars you're kind of driving
together wherever it is it's like not a
road trip but like my friend would like
like pull up at the car and like or or
like uh
i guess it was text yeah text me and be
like
uh turn on you know turn on 103 you know
turn on 105 7. this this song's on yeah
yeah you turn it on or you like pull up
to a light and then the person right
next to you or on the other side of you
is less than the same song you were i
remember they don't do they can't do i
remember my friend jim that i stayed
with in atlanta that i was talking about
he loved green day when green day like
first
and i remember there was a movie called
angus and green day did a new song on
the angus soundtrack a camera the name
of the song
and i remember we were in his car and it
was playing on the radio
and i wasn't i liked green day but i
didn't care as much and i remember right
when the dj was about to go the name of
that song is i switched the channel and
dude he turned and i wasn't i just just
out of carelessness no i wasn't being
shitty
and he looked at me and he goes i could
kill you right now
because it was like dude like no
internet i have to figure out how to
hear this no shazam yeah knowing that
you got to hear it again and then wait
and be like who is it yeah you remember
when you were listening you were like oh
and you have to wait for the dj to be
like that was the new
did you ever see the married with
children about that no
where he gets the song love and man
he gets that song go to him stuck in his
head
yeah him
folks we got a new sponsor prize picks
you like daily fantasy when it comes to
sports placing entries player
projections well prize picks
is your spot we're talking daily
fantasies as i said we're talking making
entries on the prize picks player
projections all right you know what i'm
saying you know what i'm saying
here we go let's get into it
maybe you got a thought
referring to a game where you say i'm
going to take patrick mahomes to throw
for more than 320 passing yards or and
derrick henry to rush for less than 85
yards and cooper cup to score more than
uh 45 touchdowns or tyreek hill to catch
less than 3.5 passes whatever
let's get into it the prize picks making
it easy all right
fun stuff all right so how does it work
you pick two to five players and if they
will go score more or less then your
prize prick projection you can win up to
ten times your money on an entry whew i
love it
i don't even understand sports and i
understand that it gets me excited all
right because what i do understand is
winning folks
and i'm a winner
i don't care what you say
you're not competing against other
people which i like i like taking people
out of the equation whenever possible
it's just you versus the projections
available it's safe and fast on the
withdrawals all right entries can be
made in 60 seconds or less it's that
easy i like it anyway download prize
picks the app
or go to prizepix.com and sign up and
play daily fantasy sports first time
users can receive a 100
instant deposit match up to a hundred
dollars with the promo code taste buds
if you deposit a hundred dollars prize
picks will give you a hundred dollars if
you deposit 50 prize picks will give you
50 when you use taste buds that's your
promo code use taste buds at sign up for
an instant deposit match up to a hundred
dollars prize picks
but every time they play it he catches
the end of it and they go that was one
that was that was song number six in a
list of 300 in a row here we go
because that was every radio station
back then it was like that became the
gimmick like we're going to play this
video in a row before
you won't hear a commercial sure
commercial free yeah because you people
relied on it yeah it's so wild man what
a different time i mean they used to do
the whole weekend like it was fourth of
july weekend we're like we're counting
down the top 580 songs of all time dude
remember this and i used to listen i
used to listen to it like we watched tv
i'd be like oh my god they're counting
down the top 580 songs all weekend long
remember before you could buy tv shows
on dvd
complete
and networks would do full weekend
marathons
i remember like my god dude it was
always i think fourth of july was every
fourth of july i think that was my show
actually it's awesome yeah sci-fi
channel would do the twilight zone
maryland yeah and it would be like 72
hours straight of the twilight zone and
i remember i would i put a tape in it
i would tape it and then like i remember
when i got i remember when i got the box
set i've i've re-upped several times
because my favorite tv show of all time
but when i got my first twilight zone
box set
of the original dvds
and it cost like 250 dollars it was it
was like the the way most i ever spent
on any people you felt like you were
owning the ip like you had everything at
your disposal it was such a powerful
feeling dude
i can at will it was a thing i will i
can watch every single twilight zone at
will yes like there's no chase
anymore yeah
i agree though like if i wanted to watch
every single
twilight zone episode ever if you gave
me like five
taps on my phone i would have it
it's crazy i remember being on i
remember being on opie and anthony once
and anthony was sitting there with a
thumb drive
and i go what's on that and he goes
all of seinfeld
do you know how big my box set is at
home and i was like
i remember being like holy [ __ ] you can
do that now one through nine like this
big yeah sold it again yeah like it's
crazy like it was like
and now that would seem like i used to i
used to rush home from delivering pizza
because i i my shift was five to eleven
but like if it was slow we'd pack up and
maybe get out of there by like 10 30 or
10 45 even and i lived like
eight minutes away so i would like jump
in my car at 10 45 race home so that i
could hit record at 11 o'clock for the
seinfeld that was on that night really
and i did it every single night i had
like
10 vhs's fill like six hours of vhs and
i then had a
ledger that i would write the which
episode it was so i can go and like if i
want to watch a specific episode do you
still have that i do we should put up
for auction
the volcano sign fans i have i have i
have i have a lot of it actually that's
so sick when you keep all this [ __ ]
i recently got every single one of them
digitized because i didn't know because
it was a mixture of i didn't know it was
on them and like there was old home
movies and this and that so i got them
all done and categorized and i
i think
oh maybe i after that maybe i got rid of
i did maybe after i donated a lot but i
still have a handful
you guys ever record over anything by
accident yeah man yeah i still have
i still have along with this and i will
never auction it off unless i can get it
digitized i have three
vhs tapes at home
of yom tv raps
like rap video after rap video after rap
music videos not rap mostly a rock but i
used to record music videos too i have
tapes of full vhs of all rap videos that
like
you probably couldn't even find on
youtube at this point that's cool that's
a fun thing to throw on at a party and
then all the interstitials with ed lover
and dr dre
i think i have the one where i think i
have the one on tape where the [ __ ]
cast of juice comes in wow wow and
they're all like joking with tupac and
they're like you're kind of scary in
this movie man he's like ah man you know
whatever like wow yeah like it's crazy
that's how tupac sounded
well for the bit yeah yeah for the shake
of the bit you guys have home videos i'd
love to watch some home videos of you
guys we never have too many of myself
young
i have like home videos for the last
like 15 years
but not myself young i'd have to locate
them there was like it was a couple
short ones because we didn't have that
growing up i just remember being on one
of them when my sister was a baby so you
told him 30 years ago i did have like i
accidentally taped over
um
so we had the one that went over the
shoulder i don't know if you know this
you put a full vhs cassette in it and
you held it like this
yeah with the like the shotgun like that
shotgun on the front and um my mom used
to bring it to like my hockey games in
high school and like in the stands and i
she caught it i scored a goal and i had
it on tape and i taped over it
i have i don't have videotape but you
know what i do have that my mom made me
two christmases ago
a coffee table size book
that she made documenting the first like
12 years of my life what
with like picture after picture and like
that's amazing
it was one of the nicest things
anybody's ever done and she's working on
a second book
she's doing a series
[Laughter]
but she's like she was laughing she's
like the second half does not as much
you know what i mean because you're not
taking pictures every 10 seconds but
yeah it's like it's like everything
through of me through like eighth or
ninth grade what does vhs stand for
let's find out
vcr is a video cassette recorder
yeah vh that's a great question i never
asked that question are we gonna take
guesses first video something home
video home system i was gonna say system
oh my god i guessed that but i was like
it couldn't be system yes
video home system
so that this is a vhs
no but that doesn't make any sense
because the vcr
is the apparatus that's why vhs is the
tape so why is the the tape called a
video home system
it's not a system at all
i think it just means to to work with a
video home system you know what i mean
just marketing it says here
it's a great letter it's great letters
i did want to run this past you guys
where are we
we're at like 45 minutes okay all right
the two part not as much of a three-part
three-part birthday extravaganza episode
but this is a good place to end because
now we're going to go into the battle in
the next episode we are we are
mcdonald's launches new mcflurry
sandwich now this is something
that our friend h foley of all your
garbage
would say is mcdonald's going hollywood
as he put it okay
they say with taco bell
uh
i think this is great though i mean the
mcflurry look we got a mcflurry here
it's thick it's ice cream right
it's not really
it's not a drink it's not that's a great
photo i'll tell you that much yeah it
looks appetizing and they're putting it
i love what they're doing here because
they're putting it now i argued against
the chipwich but what i like is going on
here is they got a flavored ice cream or
an ice cream with things mixed into it
chopped up and mixed into it blended in
and they're putting it between two
you can tell these are chewy cookies
yeah this is this this to me is like
this is probably a magical experience
would you agree
i would like to try it
and it's fun there's oreos and
suppose
that's what you were doing it's oreo ice
cream in between chips
no it's not
it's chips ahoy
well i mean or chocolate chip cookies
all right
actually it is oreo ice cream now what
you took in a that's a a double law no
did i lose no i did lose i lost on the
chip which right i lost on chip which
you won with two oh you won i thought
you won with classic ice cream sandwich
i did yeah i think so um did they
misspell sandwich
is there an h in sandwich you know this
bugs me too hot freestyle go to hot
freestyle's profile they write mick
broken machine because there was that
period eight years ago where mcdonald's
saw
milkshake machines we're having a hard
time but
wait go to the top i just want to see
who this is
media news company it's like why are you
still firing shots
why are you taking shots well have you
seen what radio shack's doing it's just
crazy taking shots at the king they're
trying to stay relevant radio shack like
put their twitter on the internet and
just tweeting crazy [ __ ] but now they're
selling nfts
yo radio shack i got problems with
i got multiple problems with radio shows
the most i would i would i would and i
think we could end it here
what's your take
most depressing store in the mall radio
shack right now no when we were growing
up that was the most impressive
where the hell have you seen one well i
don't know if there used to be a few
here they probably all closed down i
think they might be closed down
they would go to the mall and it was
like we had a place called classy kites
that was like
rock t-shirts and music posters and
it was bright and colorful and then
there was another place called chemas it
was like a t-shirt shop and then there
was like the record stores and all sam
goody was bright pink yeah and then you
go into radio shack and you have that
industrial carpet radio shack just two
people sprockets on bolts on the wall
and yeah [ __ ] so radio radio shack was
for the nerd like for the radio shack no
one bought
the newest tech at radio shack even
though they sold it it was always
overpriced you went to radio shack for
two reasons you were older
and you needed assistance
or the things you were working with you
needed parts for right that's really it
you go to get like those funky ass wires
that you are going to use to splice
something because you either know too
little when you go into radio shack or
you know too much you're a guy walking
into radio shack being like i want to
look at your nuts bolts wires and screws
because i'm building a rocket bomb or
you walk in and you're like i have a
tube television and i need it to look
better can someone here help me it was
never
it was a chore store
it was never a fun store radio shack you
went in in the later years
because i got a re-up on my stack of
blank cds or whatever well that's what
happened i know and you but you would go
it was never thing you wanted to buy it
was thing you had to buy
a spindle if you will
and you'd be like god man this is 22.99
for about 10. yeah
like yeah it's like dude i can go to
circus city right now it just sucks and
get 50 for 9.99 fluorescent lighting i
don't know that this exists elsewhere
they were disrespectful in that way
radio shack the price points were
disrespectful
because nobody was going in there was a
front it was a front so you can go and
then buy a splice wire for 9.99 that
allowed you to steal cable it was a
complete front you either went in there
because you knew that what the [ __ ] you
were doing or you had no idea there was
no in between people like us in between
didn't find ourselves there for any
reason
this but this can't be right if it is no
this is their account they're now
selling like nfts and trolling with this
horse [ __ ]
wait radio shack tweeted is pornhub down
for anyone else
yeah
oh my god this is the radio shack
account
and it only got a hundred and seventy
nine oh okay no cut
yeah so they're like
we're gonna play games now they're going
full adult jokes wow
i know you know what first time i'm
applauding them for something no no
no
do you know they rebranded it's like
when this is like when like when when
like
barry
caution to the wind this is like when
barry manilow comes out with like a
chain wallet on and he's like i'm cool
now and you're like no you're not just
please just be barryman well you know
what they did they they renamed
themselves the shack at one point they
had a coconut like new coke
oh god all right folks
support the pod baby subscribe to the no
press channel on youtube rate us on
itunes follow us on spotify we we you
know we say this because there's an easy
free way to support us if you like it uh
merch is on sale right now at either of
our website showderosainfo.comcounty.com
and that's it my new dates are up i said
second shows added in toronto hershey
pennsylvania and uh
atlanta
folks all full dates on sale now joe
derosa comedy on instagram and twitter
go to jotaro's info for all my upcoming
dates i think next up is san diego early
september and then somerville uh you
remember we uh we have
september
we have oh shout outs by the way thank
you to all the hellions out there from
the we'll see you in hell pod sold out
both thank you so much can i do my plugs
please thank you
sold out both shows in five minutes how
[ __ ] crazy is that
well yeah
for my other podcast maybe yeah
excellent where oh oh i mean it's not a
huge venue it's a black cat it's 50
sheets but still that's awesome yeah it
feels nice
black
dead co-host pat walsh
uh
dates coming up november or october
we'll be in north carolina there's tons
of [ __ ] happening
right now please please please please go
stop
don't
go to joeyrosesnyc.com
come see us joey rose's open tuesday
through sunday at 12 p.m every day
that's it
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste